need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself so get ready for some success
habit building wisdom from Dane Locke to
give you the motivation confidence and
belief that you need ok let's kick it
off for thrill number one build great
habits successful people have great
habits unsuccessful people have lousy
habits habits like smoking drinking
taking drugs watching too much TV
you see successful people are where they
are today because of their habits habits
determine 95% of a person's behavior
everything that you are today everything
that you accomplish in the future is
determined by the quality of the habits
that you form what I've found that is
the very best people have the best
habits you see successful people are
simply those with successful habits
successful habits could be getting up in
the morning meditate reading exercising
regularly how many of these habits do
you have rule number two don't make
excuses I'm just an introvert I'm not
good with people and I'm just like it's
ok I don't I don't like to talk out just
like that right you used as an excuse
you used that to stay in your own bubble
you used that to stay in your own shell
guess what believe it or not I was a
very very shy person I was an introvert
I was the kid when I was going through
high school I had no friends I didn't
want to talk to people because I
couldn't speak the language I'm so
afraid
even now sometimes when I go to meet a
lot of people I still sometimes have
that little bit of awkwardness it's
normal but I don't let that hold me back
I know if I want to be more successful
if I want to be rich I have to get
outside of my comfort zone I have to
overcome my shyness that's how I could
do what I do so don't use that your
personality as an excuse to hold you
back rule number three redefine failure
when you are successful you actually
experience failure much faster much much
more on a daily basis but it doesn't
matter because the ones that said yes
that's what builds your business that's
what helps you to achieve your goals so
from now on I don't want you to think of
word failure I want you I want you to be
place to what failure from from your
vocabulary from your mind instead use
this word feedback it is feedback not
failure is simply feedback from your
customers from your prospects from your
clients from the marketplace hey maybe
this offer is not what we want
or maybe the price point is not
something that they are comfortable with
or maybe the way that you articulate
you'll share your message you
communicate the value it doesn't
resonate with with the prospects of the
marketplace every single action that you
take you're gonna get some now failure
you're gonna get some feedback then
you're gonna be able to pivot you can
make changes to your approach you're
gonna learn something from it
so next time you're gonna do it just a
little bit better and knowing this
there's more feedback that you get the
faster you get those feedbacks we will
talk about Bill forward right
fail fast forget fail fast it's getting
feedback back knowing hey this is waste
of time do some work
no problem forget it now let me try this
and that more feedback maybe don't like
the feedback but that's okay it doesn't
work alright no I don't need a waste
more time and then BOOM
hey the marketplace my customers they
like this perfect that's good
now that's the feedback that you want
rule number four influence and persuade
and communication skills come in many
forms I'm talking about writing their
email or writing their social media
posts or conducting the meeting or
speaking one-on-one speaking on the
phone talking with a prospect or even
speaking to large groups of people all
those falls under communication skills
one of the things that I did that change
my life early on in my career is I
joined Toastmasters to hold and develop
my public speaking skills and what's
also learning for a mentor to develop my
cooperating skill which is communication
in the written forms how to use words in
print to persuade influence somebody so
all successful people they have this one
thing in common the ability to influence
persuade inspire other people also if
you want to have more confidence in self
love check out my 254 series they're
free the links to join are in the
description below that's a problem with
young people you're not good at anything
oh good no tell me the truth you're not
good at anything after you practice
martial art you develop this natural
self confidence not cockiness but you
develop this natural self confidence
remember this your business is always a
reflection of you rule number five don't
care what others think do you worry
how people perceive you you know you
want to do something but oh what would
people think of that
what would people think of my action
even deep down you know that's the right
thing to do but you don't do it because
you have other people's opinions ego you
let other people's opinions stop you
from doing what you know is the right
thing those people they could be your
family it could be your relatives they
could be your friends it could be your
high school buddies it doesn't matter it
could be social media you're uploading a
video you're posting on social media
you're making noise you're getting
attention suddenly you get a few haters
guess what you stop people who don't
care about you haters and trolls who add
no doubt in your life and some keyboard
warriors some losers
post a comment here like oh I guess that
hurts my feeling and you stop doing what
it's bright you stop doing what is gonna
make you successful
stop stop worrying about other people's
opinions it's just a opinion system
doesn't matter
critics haters haters gonna hate it
doesn't
you do what you know it's right rule
number six overcome adversity when
you're going through the adversities
when you're going through all these
things lonely put some distance but an
other thing that you could do is talk to
someone that has already gone through
that one of the things that I'm very
fortunate because I have a lot of peers
there are successful mentors people
around me that whatever adversity even
today that I experienced that's that
happens right which I still do that ooh
maybe like it would feel I would feel
frustrated I would feel like maybe I'm
not sure what to do but I would talk to
someone they say talk to a mentor and he
would laugh as a yep I experienced that
thirty years ago thirty five years ago
and he's what you need to do and they
would share with me my perspective
suddenly I don't feel so bad because
what happens is when you experience any
kind of problem any kind of adversity
you think you are the only one in the
world that's experiencing this not true
I could tell you from experience a lot
of people have experienced the same
things you're much luckier at least you
have a youtube channel that you could
come visit and see and get information
and get insights I didn't have any of
that back then rule number seven learn
Mark Cuban which three hours a day Bill
Gates reads at least one hour per day I
go to two to three books per week for
years now I'm still constantly learning
all the time
I'm not just talking about reading a
book it could be listening to a podcast
talking to other successful people
getting coaching from your mentors but
successful people we're always learning
and growing and we never stopped one
time I was asking a very successful
person alpha lunch it's been very
successful for so many years it's in a
merger and acquisition space he's had
multiple successful exits so multiple
companies at a very young age when we
sat down and we're sitting across each
other and when we had that
the first thing that he did is he pulled
out a journal and taking notes and
started asking me questions learning I
was the one who wanted learn from him
but it turns out into a learning session
that he's learning from me I'll never
forget that because you see the more you
know the more you will lies you don't
know the less you know the more you
think you know rule number eight
don't let ego hold you back if you want
something done you've got to do it your
self well they'll never do it as good as
the way that I do it
oh I don't trust him or I don't trust
her if you want something done you gotta
do it yourself
what you're really saying is I don't
trust other people that is ego there's a
form of ego that holds you back
because nothing great is accomplished
just with one person
it requires other people requires
teamwork so the do-it-yourself ego this
is probably one of the most common egos
that hole most people back the hole most
entrepreneurs pack that's holding them
back from going to that next level
because they are control freaks they
have this massive massive do yourself
Eagle that's holding them back rule
number nine play it smart
my whole life I've only had one job in
my entire life working in a supermarket
for one year one day I walk into the
supermarket my manager was yelling at me
calling me names and I got so fed up
with it
I said hey hey hey you and I walked out
I went home and my mom saw me and she
asked me oh how come you got off work
early what happened I said no I quit I
don't want to worked anymore it is
stupid he's a waste of time and my mom
was so concerned and so worried back
then I was making just minimum wage with
that job now do I recommend that you do
this you walk into your manager's office
your boss often say hey I quit I'm going
to now start a business I'm gonna do
something else no because I put my mom
through hell I put myself through hell
looking back what I'd have done that I'm
not so sure now I burn a ship I got that
but what I realize is most people are
not quite ready for that or they don't
have that tenacity to make it happen
just quite yet so if you're thinking
about quitting if you don't like what
you do and you're frustrated with the
people you work with or you don't like
the job you're not passionate about it
what you need to do is you need to have
some kind of a skill set verse what I
call high income skill you didn't have a
high income skill that produces income
for you before you quit wouldn't be a
smart idea because when you quit today
let me ask you this how I gonna pay your
bills I'm gonna get income coming in how
do you know the new thing that you're
doing is gonna work how do you know you
don't know so a much smarter way to
approach this is to develop your skill
first so when you have a skill that you
are selling you're offering to the
marketplace and you're actually getting
paid you're making money and I believe
the best way to do this is when you're
high income skill makes you twice as
much money compared to your current job
that you have right now that's when you
can quit then you can do this full-time
and rule number 10 the last one we four
very special bonus clip is never give up
give you down right now if you're not
where you want to be right now if you're
not successful right now
[Music]
because the signs of success are not
obvious what often looks like a failure
on the service is just a stepping stone
towards success so wherever you are in
your journey you need to realize your
adversity is your greatest advantage
your pain is your greatest tool because
happiness does not change you pain does
comfort does not move you adversity does
realize that your toughest times will
turn you into the toughest person
[Music]
what doesn't kill you will make you
stronger don't hide your pain don't run
away from your struggles use it turn
your pain into feel turn your failures
into motivation and never ever give up
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Dan on how to not follow fake gurus but
before that it's time for the free point
landing question let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go
question number one what will you commit
to learning this week number two what's
the adversity that you need to overcome
and number three how will you practice
influencing and persuading this week
following fake gurus is a great thing
about the internet is there's so much
information out there the sad thing
about the Internet is that nowadays
everyone is an expert everyone is a guru
they are telling you to do this and
don't do that everyone and their
brother-in-law in the dog it's got an
e-commerce store right now and they're
telling you they hey just follow my
system and you live the life of your
dreams my question to you is if you ask
yourself if you think critically what
qualifies them to give you advice most
of these so-called experts they come and
go I've seen it for so many years right
see the name that game is not getting
rich the name of the game is staying
rich most of these so-called gurus are
experts they're kind of fly-by-night
they do not last it's like fireworks
a lot of noise and later on nowhere to
be found
isn't it true so if you notice who you
learn from it's much more important of
what you learned are they truly proven
other models proven to work in different
market conditions and in different
circumstances and if you really dig divi
what do you think about it they would
eliminate 99% of them and these gurus
are telling you trends that might
disappear overnight
then you're building
your future on quicksand instead of on a
solid foundation
so ask yourself how these trends gonna
be around one year two year three years
five years ten years from now hi this is
Dan Locke if you're a fan of Evans work
if you want to know exactly how the
model my success I want to invite you to
join me for a special online training
all you have to do is click on a link
below you can join me for absolutely no
charge so click on link below and I will
see you in class
if you want more dan lock check at the
top 50 video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there the only difference
between me and everybody else I can
execute a better than most people we
have to understand the world revolves
around